una decisión unánime con 625 votos a
favor de los 628 emitidos el parlamento
europeo decidió poner fiel al mandato de
la eurodiputada Eva caili como
vicepresidenta
los jefes del grupo del parlamento
europeo han votado unánimemente a favor
de destituir a Eva Kylie de su cargo de
vicepresidenta del parlamento soy muy
optimista de que la vicepresidenta será
destituida antes de la Navidad el
domingo Kylie fue acusada y encarcelada
por blanqueo de capitales y corrupción
es sospechosa de haber recibido dinero
de Qatar para influir en las decisiones
económicas y políticas del parlamento
europeo a favor del emirato el caso
llega en un momento en que Qatar intenta
defender su criticado historial en
materia de Derechos Humanos a principios
de noviembre Kylie había visitado el
país elogiándolo y la única en decir que
Qatar es líder en derechos laborales con
La abolición del sistema cafala y la
introducción del salario mínimo
la fiscalía Federal belga en los 20
registros efectuados en el domicilio de
Kylie y en el de otros tres sospechosos
fueron incautadas espectaculares sumas
de dinero la autoridad griega de lucha
contra el blanqueo de capitales ha
congelado los archivos de la
eurodiputada mientras que la justicia
belga examinará el miércoles si la
mantiene o no en prisión preventiva